it's called multiple personality
syndrome disorder Alfred pause here no
it's not multiple personality syndrome
disorder Alfred Batman just six being
The Dark Knight let the psychiatrist do
the Psychiatry hey GQ I'm Dr Eric Bender
I'm a psychiatrist and psychotherapist
and today I'll be looking at some
characters from Arkham Asylum this is
the mental breakdown
[Music]
Two-Face you're a lucky man
he's not oh
new driver
Harvey Dent has become two-faced at this
point
he has a need to flip a coin to make
decisions this could be considered a
compulsion a compulsion is a behavior
you feel you have to do there's
something in you that makes you feel
like you absolutely have to do it and if
you don't it feels really uncomfortable
often a compulsion is performed to get
rid of an obsession the obsession is the
thought you have it makes you
uncomfortable makes you anxious so the
compulsion is to do something to get rid
of the obsession classical example is
someone who feels that they're dirty
that's the obsession the compulsion is
to wash their hands to feel clean to get
rid of that anxiety what might have
happened here is all the trauma that he
endured with Rachel dying and the
ambiguity of it all like what happened
what didn't he now wants clear-cut
things he's very anxious when things are
not clear-cut so he's flipping a coin
because it heads or as a tails is he
gonna die are you going to stay alive so
it's very much I want order I want to
make sure it's decided it's going to be
a or b so the compulsion to get rid of
the anxiety over things being vague is
to flip the coin Too Faced might also be
showing cognitive dissonance that part
of him that's Harvey Dent is very human
doesn't want to kill people but if it's
reduced to a coin flip it could be that
he's not killing someone he's just
obeying the coin he's just doing what
the coin says and that might be
something that
is a way for him to move forward with
his criminal life so he's not doing
something bad he's doing what is
destined to be done because of this coin
flip Riddler you inspired me you're out
of your goddamn mind
what this is all in your head you're
sick twisted how can you say that you
think you'll be remembered you're a
pathetic psychopath thank you for
attention the obsession that Riddler has
with riddles becomes somewhat pathologic
meaning it's actually causing impairment
in his daily functioning in some ways
again always looking at how the patient
presents there is a story about The
Riddler in which he didn't want to leave
a clue for Batman in the form of a
riddle he didn't want to say hey here's
this riddle see if he can solve it and
that would lead often to his being
captured he actually says to Batman I
didn't want to leave a clue I didn't
want to do it but I had to so that is
really an example of an obsession the
obsession with the riddles the
compulsion to have to say a riddle to
either feel smart the way he wants to
prove that he's smart or to challenge
himself saying he can function on the
same level as Batman so there is this
obsessive compulsive component to his
behavior Joker
I'm an agent of chaos
oh and you know the thing about chaos
beer
if I were to see the Joker I would first
of all Wonder does he belong in Arkham
Asylum
he's an individual that has come across
to me as not having any mental illness
yes something is off with him as people
say in that he commits the crimes that
he does he kills people he wants to
introduce Anarchy he tells Two-Face
introduce a little Anarchy here I just
do that's what he says he's just ready
to create chaos he's an agent of chaos
all of that makes me think
are there any real mental health issues
such as depression or anxiety or any
psychosis anything like that and I don't
see that I do wonder about anti-social
personality disorder that doesn't mean
anti-social like hey I don't want to go
associate with anybody I want to just
hang out in my room and play video games
anti-social personality disorder means
that you're actually having no regard
for laws or rules there's continual
lying there's breaking of rules and
violence might even be part of how you
get things done in this case he
certainly meets criteria for antisocial
personality disorder and I do think he's
a psychopath not all people with
antisocial personality disorder are
psychopaths
but in this case I do think he is one
given that he's a psychopath and there's
no significant mental illness
related to why he's committing the
crimes he is he doesn't belong here in
Arkham the evidence that he
first off doesn't have a mental illness
we just went through so now we look if
we're evaluating it for sanity meaning
at the time of the crime did he know
what he was doing did he know what he
was doing was wrong now I look at
additional evidence
here Commissioner Gordon says there's no
labels on his clothes everything is
designer these type of things suggest a
joker wants to be evading capture once
zero identity he knows what he's doing
is wrong now an attorney might argue
well maybe he just likes to have his
clothes made wherever well sure maybe he
has a line of clothing he likes but this
can also be seen as potential evidence
for evading capture he's also tried not
to get caught he has done things to
clearly avoid capture which means he
knows what he's doing is wrong he even
explains step by step to Harvey Dent I
am creating chaos he knows what he's
doing so not only he's not of a mental
illness he also knows what he's doing
knows what he's doing is wrong he
belongs in Black Ink penitentiary
Harley Quinn
harleen quinzel
traded me for a six-pack of beer but
however many times he tried to teach me
I kept coming back
so right away I see a kid who has been
essentially neglected by her dad traded
for a six-pack of beer she keeps trying
to come back and come back and come back
and win his affection this is actually
true in real life that somebody would do
this often I might see kids who are just
dying to get the affection of their
parents they really want to feel loved
by their mother or their father or
whatever caregivers they have there's a
drive to do that when people don't get
that affection it can really have
implications for the rest of their lives
my father used to beat me up pretty
badly anything except that every time I
got out of line bam oh sometimes I'd be
just sitting there doing nothing pow
pops tended to favor the grape you see
uh-huh this is Harley Quinn otherwise
known as harleen quinzel who apparently
was practicing as a psychiatrist at
Arkham Asylum even though she didn't
have an MD but had a PhD clearly Gotham
is corrupt as human beings without even
realizing it we tend to recreate
relationships in our lives even those
that don't serve us well it might be
dysfunctional but they're comfortable
it's something we slip back into
he or she recreates this relationship
with her father with the joker he
doesn't want her he's neglecting her
he's abusing her similar to how her
father did but she still takes it and
that's actually part of her psyche that
I would want to understand more and
talking with her
desire becomes surrender surrender
becomes
thank you
you want this
I do there is a condition called fully
Ado which means shared Madness
essentially someone is spending time
with another individual who has mental
health issues often psychosis which
means having a break from reality maybe
having some hallucinations or hearing
things and ends up sharing that same
type of issue so having their own
psychosis
what I've noticed is
Harley doesn't seem to have psychosis
nor does Joker but there is a question
of is there some type of shared at least
approach to the world some type of
shared mentality that she's picked up
after spending so much time with him if
I were to have to give a diagnosis to
Harley I would look actually in the
personality disorder category
personality disorders refer to somebody
having a vastly different way of
interacting with the world than their
cultural norm would expect in this case
Harley does have an unstable sense of
herself she doesn't feel like she's a
whole person necessarily we see that in
different ways and that could be a trait
of borderline personality disorder or
just a borderline trait meaning she
doesn't have a full personality disorder
but what fits Harley most is histrionic
personality disorder or histrionic
traits someone with histrionic
personality disorder is very
uncomfortable unless they're the center
of attention they might use sexual
and behavior to get attention or they
have a physical appearance they make up
and you can see that she does that so
that she will get get that attention
someone with histrionic personality
disorder might also have a shallow
expression of emotions they might have a
very unique way of speaking that's
somewhat dramatic and they might have a
real dramatic Flair to how they present
all these things categorize her so far
one of the main things though is someone
with histrionic personality disorder is
very suggestible the things that Harley
does subject herself to for Mr Jay's
love they're actually really horrific
when you think about it so when people
talk about wanting to have this kind of
mad love relationship
I don't know how well that would serve
them in the real world there's a
syndrome called Florence Nightingale
syndrome where the caretaker falls in
love with the patient
it's been suggested by a psychologist in
England that that's actually what's
going on in this particular case Harley
does find this way of attaching and I
think this is it it's this shared
feeling of not being loved the Joker is
manipulating her here though and she
doesn't see that she's blinded by that
desire to actually feel loved Mad Hatter
I'll cut that cowl off your neck before
you'll take her I've waited my whole
lonely life for her then all you've
waited for is a puppet
he seems to be convinced that he's a
character in Alice in Wonderland that
makes me think of two things in
particular on my differential diagnosis
list I wonder if is there a form of OCD
where he's so obsessed with Alice in
Wonderland
that he ends up
compulsively living in that world
dressing up that way even kidnapping a
girl who is Alice there is OCD
obsessive-compulsive disorder where one
has that Obsession and the compulsions
and behavior that you do to get rid of
the anxiety from the
Obsession but you can have what's called
poor Insight where you don't recognize
that these are intrusive thoughts that
these are thoughts that actually don't
match with a realistic situation that
you don't need to double check triple
check quadruple check your locks in the
door that you don't need to make sure
the oven is off 20 times
so it could be that he has OCD before
Insight but
seems to be more delusional something
that he really Embraces from a young age
where he just continues to live in this
world it brings up an interesting
question of where is fanaticism whether
it's being a fan of a sports team being
a fan of a game being a fan of a cartoon
a comic where does fandom end and
something that's more delusional begin I
look at whether something really impacts
someone's functioning in this case
he's functioning in this world where
he's kidnapping young girls so this is
clearly a disorder when it reaches the
level of impacting somebody's daily
functioning Mad Hatter might also have
some pedophilic Tendencies he's
essentially zombified her Mad Hatter
likes to put mind control devices into
hats there's actually
story in which Mad Hatter put mind
control devices into tape players and
gave them out to young dick Grayson's
female classmates at school
the idea was that he was then going to
sell these girls into slavery to a
corrupt millionaire
[Music]
here I see an obsession with hats he's
going from one hat to the next looking
at all of these hats and they make him
so proud it's not just a collection it's
something more there's almost
something he gets out of this that's
like a narcissistic thing and the reason
I know that is he says the next place is
here for Batman's cowl that's my next
one so he has this way that reminds me
of a serial killer where they take
trophies which to them are proof of
their skills look at what they've done
I'm reminded of that with Jervis touch
the Mad Hatter he looks at each of these
hats and thinks about what he's done and
how he's won over these individuals
whether he's killed them or not
in the 1966 version of Batman we just
don't know they didn't really allude to
that so much so he has this Psychopathic
almost vengeful side to get back at
people he's got all those jurors right
there in the closet ready to in some
ways collect something from them too in
real life there are serial killers do
the same thing Ed Gein used to take the
skin from his victims and make
lampshades or clothing even out of them
to have a trophy around Mr zaz fly away
from this world
I'm saving a special spot for you
right here
in taking a history of Mr zaz you
learned that he was on a bridge ready to
die by Suicide when someone came and
mugged him someone came up to him with a
knife Mr zazz ends up actually killing
that person and he feels that he's doing
a favor to humanity by freeing people of
this horrible existence and from that
moving on he decides he's going to go
ahead and kill people
and every mark on his body is for one
killing so he'll carve it into himself
Mr zaz actually is a psychopath he
doesn't care he doesn't love he doesn't
have any kind of
attachment to people other than using
them for what he wants
we see that here in the scene where he
realizes that the teenage kid has
swallowed this diamond
he's going to cut her open he doesn't
care this is a kid he doesn't care it's
a person he just wants what he wants and
he's going to do what he wants to get it
there's nothing that is psychotic about
him there's no break from reality he
doesn't seem depressed he might be
depressed at times but depression
doesn't link to his violence he doesn't
have any anxieties here he is a
psychopath
the ventriloquist and Scarface
we got us a Squealer no boss that can't
be none of us want to screw up a sweet
deal like this glad to hear it Mugsy
because if there isn't I find them at
stripes for that rat
Scarface remember your
blood I want your opinion dummy I'll
pull your string
here we see the ventriloquist and his
dummy Mr Scarface in this version of the
story that I see the ventriloquist
says Mr Scarface is his own person he
believes he's someone totally different
at the same time the ventriloquist is
clearly using his voice to voice Mr
Scarface this could be considered a
dissociative identity disorder the
sister identity disorder used to be
called multiple personality disorder I
don't think that's the case here because
this individual is going back and forth
from one personality to the next that's
not how this presents when somebody has
dissociative identity disorder somebody
with did it's called
would actually have one personality
present
for usually some amount of time and then
the next one would present for some
amount of time there's not going to be
this going back and forth like this that
would be extremely rare
[Music]
it's called multiple personality
syndrome disorder Alfred pause here no
it's not multiple personality syndrome
disorder Alfred that Manchester being
The Dark Knight let the psychiatrist do
the Psychiatry when Batman's standing in
front of Wesker and they hear the voice
of Scarface from the other room
again that's information that suggests
they're two separate people unless
Wesker is such a gifted ventriloquist
he's not even moving his lips in any way
to throw his voice and Batman does
wonder that you see Batman in the
Batcave talking to
Alfred about the different wave patterns
that play out when he's recorded Wesker
and Scarface
he's showing different physical
manifestations of each character and
that actually can happen in real life if
someone has the social identity disorder
one of the Alters might even have a
different physical presence than the
others one might have a limp or one
might have a medical issue one might
even have an accent that kind of
physical difference can in fact happen
here it's with a voice
Maxi Zeus
Be not Afraid my muse
one star has been cleansed by the fire
from Olympus Thou shalt be as a goddess
at my side throughout eternity
[Music]
this believes he's a Greek god he's
talking about Mount Olympus the ancient
Greek gods where Zeus Hera other people
who are living this weapon he's created
is going to fire the fires from Mount
Olympus so there's something not quite
right in what he's thinking
a psychotic disorder means that somebody
has a break from reality and they might
have a delusion or a belief that is
fixed and firm even though it's false
that's one part of psychosis another
could be hallucinations hearing things
seeing things other people don't see
another part of a psychotic disorder
could be disorganized thoughts things
don't flow things are just going from
one place to the next in one's head
Maxi Zeus doesn't show all of those he
does show delusional thinking but he
doesn't show hallucinations disorganized
thinking and delusions
that would often go with schizophrenia
schizophrenia is a break from reality
but someone has hallucinations they
often have the disorganized thought that
I mentioned earlier he doesn't have that
so what he actually has if I had to give
a diagnosis is delusional disorder that
means that he has a fixed false belief
and no matter what as I'm spending time
with him letting him know have you
considered that perhaps we don't live in
ancient Greece have you considered this
he's not buying any of it he's
continuing in this way of being that
shows he's this powerful God
so to me that means this guy is
delusional
no this is truly Olympus surely it can
be no other place
this beautiful Demeter goddess of the
Harvest
[Music]
and double-faced Janus Lord of
beginnings and endings
Maxi Zeus is walking through the
hallways of Arkham and he's commenting
that each individual is a Greek god or
goddess he's really stuck in this
delusional world this isn't what's
called Waxing and waning where it's
going away and then it comes back and
going away and comes back constantly
there that's more of a sign that this is
a delusional disorder
Mr Freeze I want to live like this
prisoner in the world you can see but
never touch
old and infirm as you are I'd trade a
thousand of my frozen years for your
worst day in Psychotherapy you're often
taught
to think about how you feel when you're
sitting with a patient because that can
give you some Clues as to what the
patient might be feeling
I feel extremely sad when I sit with Mr
Freeze he's somebody who yeah he wants
to take over the world and freeze it all
but what I feel sad about is that he is
incredibly lonely
when you see here the millionaire come
up to him and say I want to live like
you he says what are you insane he's
using it colloquially there not by legal
definition insane because he knows how
lonely this existence is he says there's
this is a horrible loneliness I wouldn't
want this for anybody
it is incredibly painful to think about
not being in touch we're not literally
physically touching another human being
for the rest of your life and he's
really stuck with that sadness in
addition the sadness he experiences with
the loss of his wife all of his
experiments were about how to help his
wife Nora with a terminal illness
survive how could she live so he's alone
he's still pining for his wife there is
that incredible sadness he still has
there might be some element of
complicated grief here where even after
all this time he knows his wave is not
there but he still focuses on her death
and focuses on those people that caused
him to have this condition so that he
couldn't help his wife he's in an
incredible amount of pain some people
ask if Mr Freeze might have schizoid
personality disorder excuse with
personality disorder means that someone
doesn't have any desire for
relationships and they actually don't
want any human contact that's not Mr
Freeze in my opinion he actually would
love he says I give up a thousand of my
days for one of your worst days
it's really sad
I don't think he necessarily has a
mental health diagnosis sometimes I see
people who don't have a diagnosis they
just need some support
penguin
[Music]
did you miss me
penguin grew up in really difficult
circumstances he was born with this
deformity and his parents decided they
were so ashamed of the deformity it was
going to drop him in the sewer he ended
up being raised with animals at a zoo
and he is this incredibly deformed adult
now who's very very angry and murderous
trauma that happens when you're younger
really does have an impact on your life
it doesn't make you want to become a
murderous individual necessarily that's
pretty rare but here we see penguin
really focusing on all that pain wanting
other people to feel the pain of losing
their children or wanting to make sure
that kids aren't
with their parents and and he's
dispersing this pain that somewhere is
in the roots of his own existence it's
incredibly traumatic to feel like you're
not wanted that you're not loved even as
an adult we see how those scars play out
and how they impact someone
the penguin in some ways wants to be
loved but he's not giving that message
by being this dark and focusing on crime
so that's going to be hard for him to
convey
therapy that's the kind of thing I would
work on with him is to say okay are you
doing anything that's giving the message
that you really want to be connected
with people I would attempt to point out
to him that stealing children is not
giving that message
Arkham's pretty corrupt there are a lot
of people here that don't belong in a
forensic hospital if you got a lot of
Forensic psychiatrists in here to
evaluate the individuals I have a
feeling a lot of them would be
determined to go to Blackgate
Penitentiary instead of Arkham Asylum I
always want to remind people that mental
illness does not lead to violence you're
15 times more likely to be struck by
lightning than killed by a stranger with
chronic psychotic illness good treatment
can be helpful I'm not saying that good
treatment would cure Joker or penguin or
Mr zazz but good treatment is important
it's important to find it's important to
offer and I need to talk to some people
around here about getting new
psychiatrists at Arkham thank you